this is a Supreme Court sanctioned
murder of what little actual democracy
is left in this democracy if you are a
regular person who's ever made a
campaign donation before forget about
ever having to do that again what's the
point it is the dark ages it is our Dred
Scott last week the Supreme Court
reversed essentially a law and I believe
will open the floodgates for special
interests including foreign corporations
to spend without
[Applause]
whoa what's got this trio of Patriots so
riled up about the end of free speech in
America ironically it's a Supreme Court
ruling about a political film that was
actually censored by the federal
government the Citizens United case
revolved around Hillary the movie an
anti Hillary Clinton documentary put
together by the group Citizens United
lower courts had ruled that ads for the
film or pay-per-view showings violated
the bipartisan campaign Reform Act of
2002 which is also known as
mccain-feingold mccain-feingold strictly
limited what independent groups could
say about politicians just before an
election and the Supreme Court ruled
that such laws violate the First
Amendment so why is everybody all bent
out of shape about big corporations
taking over well citizens united is a
type of corporation it's a 501 C 4
non-profit and the Supreme Court ruled
that groups of individuals who come
together should have the right to make
their political views known before an
election as long as they're not
coordinating with another political
campaign to call the apocalyptic
rhetoric about the Citizens United
decision overheated is a massive
understatement for at least three
reasons twenty-six states already allow
corporate donations in this context do
you think places like Utah Missouri and
Virginia are more corrupt than states
that don't allow corporations to voice
opinions on political matters for
decades many corporations have been
intricately and meshed in the political
process even going so far as to publicly
support specific candidates and specific
pieces of legislation you know them
better by names like the New York Times
The Wall Street Journal the Washington
Post USA Today the Los Angeles Times and
basically every major newspaper in the
country if we can withstand the New York
Times telling us who to vote for
we can probably withstand Exxon Mobil
trying to tell us to vote for Sarah
Palin or against Joe Biden more speech
is never a bad thing whether it's funded
by citizens united or by Microsoft or by
the Teamsters Union and it's especially
not a bad thing right before an election
when politics matters most if you want
to get exercised over something don't
get bent out of shape over a court
ruling that act
increases free speech instead turn your
eye on a government that is vast and
growing and helps her hinders
corporations based on political lobbying
rather than marketplace forces
[Music]
you